خلينا نوقف دقيقه قبل لا دلال تاخذ قرار
مصيري فيما يخص حياتها المهنيه والعمليه
طبعا تبون تعرفون شنو صار نطروا شويه في
الفيلم شفناه حكايه دلال وجاسم اثنين شباب
كويتيين بداوا حياتهم العمليه مع بعض
اشتغلوا بنفس اليوم وتدرجه شوي شوي في
حياتهم حتى وصلنا الى المقطع اللي شفناه
اخر شيء دلال قاعد تطرش مسج حق شخص تبي
تاخذ قرار فيما يخص حياتها العمليه بما ان
اليوم موضوعنا
فخلينا ننظر مو من منظور سياسي اجتماعي
حقوق الانسان اللي هو خلينا نشوف من
منظور تاثير قرار دلال على الاقتصاد
والتنميه المستدامه
شنو علاقه قرار دلال في التنميه المستدامه
خلينا نشوف الكويت سوق العمل الكويتي خلنا
نشوف القطاع الخاص فيه 70 الف كويتي
وكويتيه يشتغلون في القطاع الخاص منهم
ناخذ البنوك بالذات لانهما اكبر جهه
يعينون فيها قطاع خاص كويتيين خمسين
بالمئه دلال 50% جاسم ولكن مثل ما شفنا
بالفيلم معاه مرور الزمن ومع تسلق
الترقيات ومع الوصول الى المناصب القياديه
نوصل من 50% جاسم وخمسين بالمئه دلال حتى
المناصب القياديه 90% جاسم عشره بالمياه
دلال
في ما يسمى
عالمياكس يقيس تمكين المراه على اربع
محاور خلينا نشوف اول السوق الكويتي السوق
الكويتي القوى العامله اجمالا هناك 60%
دلال 40% جاسم ولكن من الستين بالميه دلال
اللي في سوق العمل الكويتي
86% منهم يختار انه هو يشتغل فيه القطاع
الحكومي طبعا الشباب ما تختلف الارقام 80%
منهم يشتغل في القطاع الحكومي هذا طبعا
قاعد يسبب عبء على الدوله اكثر من نصف
ميزانيه بنك من نصف ميزانيه الدوله قاعده
تروح على بند الرواتب
تمام اذا كانت هذه الوضعيه والاقتصاد اللي
احنا فيه الحين وضعت الدوله سياسات
ومبادرات على اساس انها تقوي من القطاع
الخاص وتشجع الشباب انه هم يشتغلون في
القطاع الخاص فمن هذه الاستراتيجيات خطه
الكويت عشرين خمسه وثلاثين عشان الاقتصاد
والتنميه المستدامه
شنو تاثير قرار دلال على التنميه
المستدامه والاقتصاد في الكويت عالميا
هناك ما يسمى
بالجندرز مؤشر يقيس مدى تمكين المراه في
المجتمعات على اربع محاور السياسه
الاقتصاد الصحه والتعليم لما يكون هناك
الجاندركس في الدول خل نقول عالميا ايه هي
الجند 68 وفي الكويت الجاندكس 63% شنو
يعني بمعنى ان دلال تحصل على فقط
63% من الريزورسز والموارد اللي يحصل
عليها جاسم
السؤال سوت سوت ثبت علميا ومن خلال
الدراسات ومن خلال البحوث بان عالميا كل
ما قدرنا ان احنا نسكر
ممكن نضيف الى الجي دي بي ما يقارب
العشرين ترليون دولار وهذا شنو يعني
بالنسبه للكويت بالكويت يعني ان هناك فرص
ضائعه فرص ضائعه بعدم استغلال هذه الموارد
البشريه قيست على انها تقريبا 23 بليون في
السنه سنويا وفي الاميه 115 سنه اللي هي
الفتره اللي احنا نتوقع انها تاخذ
نتواصل الى تمكين المراه راح ياخذ ما
يقارب 750 بليون تكلفه من
لوستنتي في الكويت
من وين اللص خليني اقول لكم تدرون ان كل
جاسم يتخرج من الجامعه تتخرج ثلاثه دلال
وحق دراسات العليا حق كل جاسم يتخرج من
الجامعه تخرج ثلاثه يعني سوق العمل من
موارد البشريه في الكويت دلال تمثل ثلاث
اضعاف جاسم من حمله الشهادات
الفرص الضائعه من وين يايا دلال طبعا يعني
درست وتعلمت وصرفت عليها الدوله واستثمرت
فيها اذا ما استغلت كموارد بشريه في تنميه
القطاع الخاص وفي الانتاجيه وفي ان هي
تكون انسانه منتجه في المجتمع هذه طبعا
تكلفه على الدوله وطبعا كلنا ندري ان دلال
هي اللي تصرف اكثر فدلال اذا كان عندها
امكانيه وعندها قدره شرائيه راح تصرف في
السوق وراح تنفق اكثر فهذا راح يكون كله
لا مردود في تمكين المراه وراح يكون فيه
مردود اقتصادي بحث على السوق الكويتي وبعد
الدراسات كمان احنا كنا نبي نشجع القطاع
الخاص الدراسات كمان قاعده تقول ان
الشركات اللي عندها تمكين حق المراه وتؤمن
في اعطاء اصحاب المهن
والكولفكيشنز المراكز اللي هم يستاهلونها
حسب الكفاءه وحسب الاداء وليس على النوع
تكون عندها الارباح عشره الى 15% اكثر
وتكون الانتاجيه فيها اكثر وطبعا يعني اذا
قلنا ان الشركه عندها سياسات تشجع الاداء
فهذه الشركات راح تكون طبعا سمعتها افضل
والمعلامه التجاريه افضل وعندها القدره
انها هي تستقطب من سوق العمل افضل الايدي
العامله والمواهب الموجوده لان الشركه كل
يبي يشتغل فيها تمام فاذا قلنا ان كل هذه
الاشياء الموجوده في السوق ان الاقتصاد
راح ينمو بوجود دلال انه هي تكون انسانه
منتجه في داخل سوق العمل وهي الانسانه
المثقفه المتعلمه اللي صرفت عليها الدوله
بدلات تتجه الى انه هي تكون عب على
الحكومه انها تكون انسانه منتجه مربحه
وتساعد على انعاش السوق الكويتي الوضع اذا
اذا كانت هذه المعطيات لماذا اذا الوضع
كما هو الحين
على القرار اللي راح تاخذه دلال شفنا ظروف
دلال وشفنا انها وصلت الى مرحله انها هي
تاخذ قرار مثل هذا النوع
الارض غير متساويه الظروف غير متساويه
دلال ظروفها غير جاسم سواء اجتماعيه سواء
ضغوطات شخصيه
تكوينها ايه هي
كامراه عايشه في مجتمع ذكوري والقدرات
وعدم الثقه في النفس وكل هذه الاشياء
درسناها انا في يوم من الايام كنت دلال
حتى وصلت الى ما وصلت عليها الحين عقب 35
سنه في الموارد البشريه عاشرت وايد دلال
فالوضع اللي هي فيه الحين الشخص اللي هي
قاعد تكتب له الحين الجواب اللي راح يرد
عليها شنو راح يكون من خلال تجربتنا عرفنا
ان هناك ما يسمى بالمثلث الاستراتيجي
المثلث الاستراتيجي مكون من اصحاب القرار
والقياده وواضعي السياسات الضلع الثاني من
من المثلث جاسم والضلع طبعا الثالث اللي
هو دلال واضعي السياسات واخذيه القرارات
وهما اللي يقدروا اللي مؤمنين في ان وجود
دلال له في التنميه الاقتصاديه وانها راح
تكون هذه الطريقه الوحيده اللي يكون عندنا
تنميه مستدامه فنضع السياسات لان ندري ان
الارض غير متساويه
وظروفهم مختلفه فالسياسات التي توضع لازم
تاخذ في عين الاعتبار ان دلال راح يكون
عندها عواقب وتشالنجز مختلفه فلازم ان
احنا نمهد لها هذا الطريق ماخذين في عين
الاعتبار والفقره اللي هي فيها الحين راح
تعدي متى ما عدت هذه الفقره وتبتدي هي
تمسك زمام الامور توصل الى المناصب
القياديه
الجزء الثاني من المثلث جاسم طبعا جاسم
الزوج الاخ الزميل المدير صاحب القرار ما
راح تخلص الموضوع في انه دلال يصير عندها
تمكين الا ما يكون جاسم مؤمن في ان دلال
هي حاجه اقتصاديه وان وجودها يثري سوق
العمل وان احنا نقدر بهذه الطريقه ناخذ
التنميه المستدامه
واخر شيء واهم شيء اللي هو دلال دلال لازم
يكون عندها الطموح والشغف في انها هي
تستمر في حياتها العمليه وان هذا راح تعدي
هذه المرحله وراح توصل حق اللي تبيه ولكن
يبي له شويه صبر لان الظروف صعبه
والمواجهه هذه هي مثل ما تخطت هذه الخطوه
راح توصل الى المناصب العليا وتكون ايه هي
انسانه معطاءه منتجه في المجتمع
السؤال اللي سالته دلال اقعد في سوق العمل
او استقل تبون تعرفون شنو الاجابه عندنا
في الجمهور اليوم من اصحاب القرار من
المثلث الاستراتيجي في المدير الاخ الزوج
الزميل عندنا من اصحاب القرار وعندنا ما
شاء الله مجموعه كبيره من جاسم وعندنا
مجموعه كبيره من دلال فالسؤال اللي راح
نرد عليه حق دلال متروك لكم اعضاء المثلث
الاستراتيجي شنو راح تردون على دلال
ومشكورين
[تصفيق]